you get the cool mom card for this I
mean I don't know do I get the cool mom
card Kyle Richards and her daughter
Portia were an adorable duo at 102.7
kiss FM's Wango Tango concert on
Saturday The Real Housewives of Beverly
Hills star dish to ET about her sister
Kim her co-stars and whether she'll
return to housewives for another season
how are things with the family house Kim
doing she's great she's so excited about
the baby coming the two babies but it's
she's really good the baby shower
yesterday was beautiful was really
exciting two of my niece's are having
babies Nikki and Brooke Kim's daughter
and Kathy's daughter so it's just an
exciting time our family's growing and
to see you know all of my nieces and my
daughter's they're all holding together
it was just a beautiful day so I got up
in the middle of the night and wrote an
email to Kyle how are things of you and
Yolanda lately you know we're fine I
mean like she said we're okay you know
we didn't have you know any major
problems but we're okay I mean I'm
actually fine with all the women I don't
understand some of the things you do but
I'm sure you don't understand some of
the things I do either you will end of
season two I feel like you were good
with Lisa Rinna but you're also delusive
van der Pauw I mean there's been things
obviously that hurt my feelings you know
or things I don't agree with but you
know they're all great ladies they are
what hurts the your feelings the most uh
well this season it was just things that
Mesa run ahead said about my sister Kim
I told her you're making it difficult to
maintain her friendship with you by
doing that but she you know she did feel
bad apologize so we kind of moved on
from that and I'm one to like you know
move on like Oh things so I'm fine now
you're gonna be shooting the next season
we'll be back I mean nothing's confirmed
yet but I've been here a long time